an Oregon woman's attempt to connect
with her daughter's anonymous sperm
donor is raising difficult questions
about the practice and may even lead to
a lawsuit
Danielle Teuscher told us she used a DNA
test from 23andme and then reached out
to one of her daughter's genetic
relatives but Northwest Cryobank were
that she received the sperm donation
then sent her a cease and desist letter
and a Warner spoke to usher who says her
plan for more children genetically
related to her daughter is now in
jeopardy and a good morning good morning
well it's one woman's story of
unexpected consequences that raises
complicated questions can anyone who's a
donor expect anonymity when so many
people are connecting and finding
genetic relatives online daily she's
really into music singing she's a very
athletic very strong Danielle tortures
five-year-old daughter Zoe is one of
thousands of children conceived with
sperm from an anonymous donor and she's
definitely a social butterfly which she
did not get from me ooh I sure wanted to
know more about her daughter's ancestry
and possible health issues so when she
and other family members decided to get
DNA tests from company 23andme over the
holidays she added one for Zoe and lo
and behold turned up what appeared to be
one of the anonymous donors relatives I
imagine you were surprised shocked yes
and it sounds like you didn't go looking
for that no not at all the donated sperm
had come from Northwest Cryobank which
offers donors anonymity but twice sure
says the apparent relative she found on
23andme listed themselves as open to
messaging I said I don't want to cross
any boundaries I just want to let you
know that we're out here and we're open
to contact if you are the relative
responded I don't understand so Twitter
says she let it go but then she got this
a cease and desist letter from Northwest
Cryobank telling her not to contact the
donor or learn more information about
his identity background or whereabouts
the bank warned it could seek $20,000 in
liquidated damages worst of all she says
it took back for additional vials of
donor sperm that
purchased sperm she'd planned to use to
have Zoey's genetic siblings so what was
that like for you getting that
devastating I mean it's shocked I was
crying for days like I could barely eat
because I lie
I felt embarrassed almost like here I
thought I was doing this thing I thought
was in the best interest of my daughter
and then I just came back on me in just
such a harsh way that made me feel like
a ok I did something terrible like I was
a criminal
Northwest Cryobank told us it does not
prohibit DNA testing but said concern
arises when one uses DNA test results to
contact a donor and/or his family the
bank says clients like Teuscher have
contractually agreed to not
independently seek the identity or
attempt to contact these individuals
Teuscher says that contract was online I
mean you just click the boxes plus she
says it's not all about her my daughter
is an actual living breathing feeling
human being who did not sign that
contract and contracts or not many donor
conceived children and their families
are finding each other all of us
thousands of us have made these
connections
Wendy Kramer runs the donor sibling
registry a group that connects donor
conceived children and their families
her own donor conceived son has found 18
half siblings most of them through DNA
test matches it's a right for everybody
to know the truth about their their own
DNA their own background their relatives
and their medical histories Northwest
Cryobank says not all donors will want
that opportunity it told us there's a
human being on the other side of the
gift who may have a partner parents job
and children of his own an uninvited
contact could jeopardize these
relationships and families but experts
say in 2019 that contact may simply be
unavoidable dr. Peter McGovern is an
infertility specialist the problem we
have now is that the science has kind of
overstepped
where we are in terms of legality do you
think that it's even possible to promise
someone that they will remain anonymous
as a donor in the current environment I
think despite our best efforts we cannot
promise that anymore but Teuscher says
with the loss of her vials the promise
of more children may be ended for her
they literally took my babies my future
babies now after we contacted Northwest
cryo Bank for this story
a representative sent TOI sure an email
saying the bank would refund the money
she paid for those additional vials of
her donors sperm but did not offer to
give her vials back the representative
we spoke to the same one at Northwest
cryo Bank told us that this is the only
letter threatening legal action that
they've ever sent to a client to his
knowledge but complicated questions
pinions on both sides here it's very
interesting because we have more and
more people who experience infertility
they use egg donors they use sperm
donors for lots of different different
reasons and the law has to catch up with
this because some people want to help
but they do won't want to remain
anonymous right and in some countries
for example the UK when a child turns 18
a donor conceived child anonymity is
gone there are countries where they've
just wiped away the N and then many in
fact Northwest Cryobank told us that
they now have a more similar procedure
to that for many of these cases as well
how that will affect others yeah thank
you